- The whole purpose of
being on this planet
is to learn more about each
other
and learn more about
the place where we are.
We are curious by nature.
I'm Erica Bergman.
I'm a submarine pilot,
and a National Geographic
Explorer.
Being a submarine pilot,
is my absolute dream job.
It is unusual down there, in
such an awe inspiring way.
The ocean is 75% of the planet.
The majority of life on
Earth, is in the ocean.
When National Geographic and
Coors Light approached me
about my My Next, they said
what's on your bucket list.
I went bold.
I was like, I want to go to
space.
They said we can't do that.
I said I still want to go up.
I want to see the world
from the opposite direction.
I wanted to come to the jungle.
I wanted to climb into the
canopy.
Costa Rica has 10 different
climate zones.
Everything from tropical rain
forests
to coastal ecosystems.
Curiosity keeps me excited about
life.
Look inside yourself and
find that thirst for more.
Find your next adventure.